We've been looking for the,
for the,
for the last few lectures at the ethics and the theology that have throughout
paradise lost been produced.
At least this has been my argument been produced and sanctioned by Milton's
narrator.
And so we learned for example,
both from the narrator and also from Raefiel that eve is inferior to Adam and on
the authority of the narrator and of Raefiel,
the social hierarchy of Eden is established as what we can think of as the,
this is what also I've been arguing,
um,
it's been established as the dominant discourse of the poem.
And we can think of this as the poems official doctrine if a poem can be said to
have an official doctrine,
but there's obviously so much more to paradise lost then the official discourses
of Raphael and the narrator.
The poem seems continually,
and this is also what I've been arguing,
continually opening up spaces for ideas other than the official sanctioned
language of the narrator that the angel wrap you'll,
you'll remember was,
was eager to assert the hierarchical or hierarchical worldview when the,
when the narrator was speaking
about Adam [inaudible] when the narrator was speaking about Adam and eve.
But as we saw last time,
uh,
Raffia was willing to loosen the constraints of the notion of hierarchy when he
was pondering the subject of astronomy.
Rafiel is,
astronomy was marked really wonderfully by a lot of doubt and uncertainty.
And he refused to determine whether a Ptolemy was right or whether Copernicus
was right.
And there's a way in which the poems doubt about one kind of hierarchy,
uh,
seem to bleed over into the other forms of hierarchy with which the poem was
also concerned that that was essentially the phenomena.
That's a little recap of the last lecture now so far in paradise lost,
uh,
that the tension between the poems official line and what we can think of is
it's more subversive strains.
This tension has surfaced in paradise lost in a kind of contrapuntal fashion.
One position is simply juxtaposed without comment,
uh,
juxtaposed with another.
Um,
but the poem itself never,
never seems explicitly in any way to acknowledge the presence of the conflict or
the presence of the contradiction.
That is,
the poem doesn't seem to acknowledge the presence of the conflict or
contradiction until now until book nine.
Book Nine,
which is the book of the fall is structured by I think a far more explicit
opposition of that official,
the,
the dominant discourse on the one hand and a much more open ended critique of
that discourse on the other.
And the stark opposition between these two competing positions is manifest
explicitly for me,
is manifest explicitly in the argument between Adam and Eve,
the morning of the fall,
uh,
before their separation.
But
before we actually look at the content of that absolutely remarkable argument,
it's,
it's worth musing on the fact that Adam and eve are having an argument at all.
It's,
it's amazing for the,
for that matter that they're actually conversing in the conversation between
Adam and eve before Eve's departure to work alone.
We have what I think has to be the first conversation on earth,
the first genuine dialogue,
a conversation that,
well there,
there may be a very brief exception in book five,
but we're,
we'll set that aside.
A conversation that involves two individuals who do not already have in mind the
content of the other speech,
a conversation.
And of course I'm thinking of all of the conversations that we have or that you
have with one another,
is a conversation that possesses at least some element of epistemological
uncertainty,
an element of surprise,
the inability to know exactly what the other person is going to say before he
says it.
Now,
Milton,
up to this point,
has it been able to represent anything like this genuine dialogue?
Um,
there,
there are some exceptions,
maybe the dialogue between Satan and ab deal during the war in heaven,
but on earth it's not so clear,
uh,
before this moment,
all language is more or less ceremonial or ritualistic utterance.
Uh,
so I'm,
let's think of the father and the son in the dialogue and heaven in book three,
the father's Omniscience,
the fact that he knows everything,
it makes dialogue absolutely impossible.
He always knows in advance with the sun is going to say,
and even with Adam and eve,
um,
but before book nine,
yeah,
Adam and eve seem to know in advance in some way the content of the other
speech.
And so Adam will be getting a speech and this happens all the time with some
variation of this little formula.
Uh,
well thou knowest eve that blah,
blah,
blah.
Of course,
you know this eat,
but I'm going to say it,
I'm going to say it anyway and,
and an evil tell Adam that day.
I often remember.
And then she will proceed to tell him something that presumably that she's
already told them a number of times before conversation before this point has
been ritualistic.
It's been ceremonial and it is essentially unnecessary,
uh,
in the,
in these early parts of the poem.
But the dialogue between Adam and eve at the scene of their separation is,
is really different from the ceremonial utterances.
They're there for the first time.
They're speaking speak speeches from uh,
alien perspectives with purposes and intentions that are foreign to one another.
They sound,
they seem to us,
uh,
familiar.
We recognize we recognize these people and in this conversation,
and it's actually an argument as much as it is a conversation,
Milton is giving us an emblem.
Finally,
I think an emblem of what this poem has been doing all along this poem has been
arguing with itself.
The,
the dominant and official language of hierarchy has been pitting itself against
the questioning of subversive language of equality.
And,
and here in this conversation,
Milton gives a dramatic shape to what has been here too,
for the abstract,
the intellectual conflict that had so textured,
uh,
so many of the earlier books.
And so here in book nine,
at the moment of the separation between Adam and eve,
we can see these two worldviews,
these two enormous,
uh,
the ways in which paradise lost thinks,
um,
separate almost to the point of,
of absolute in compatibility.
And whether this,
uh,
whether this divergence will be merely a separation or whether it will be an
actual divorce.
Um,
I think is an open question.
Now you can think of Milton assigning faces here in book nine,
uh,
two to a lot of these positions that have fear to for Ben Abstract.
Um,
Adam represents in this dialogue the nervous voice of the poems,
Orthodoxy and Eve represents the questioning voice,
the voice that questions or critiques that Orthodoxy.
And,
and,
and to his credit,
and Milton's not often given credit for this,
he goes out of his way to lend a certain authority to eaves critique.
And he does so by structuring her argument as a retrospective,
something like a retrospective of his own career as a radical polemicist.
So eve takes up the role of the radical Milton in this,
in this scene.
She's put in the strange and utterly fascinating position of quoting Milton,
quoting the younger Milton.
And you have something like a recap in this speeches of eve here in this
discussion with Adam,
a recap of the great moments in this writer's work.
Now,
the first subject of their discussion involves the topic that has been
absolutely central and we know this,
uh,
to Milton throughout his career.
And this is the subject of work or labor,
the essentially the value of human activity.
Um,
and so the ostensible premise for the separation of Adam and eve on the morning
of the fall is Eve's desire to work separately from Adam.
Eve is arguing that they will be more productive,
there'll be more productive if they divide their labors.
And,
and,
and so think of the ways in which this resonates for us.
Milton has been juxtaposing for years.
The two accounts of the value of labor that he had found in the New Testament,
the parable of the workers in the vineyard and the parable of the talents.
And as early as Sonnet a sonnet seven written when Milton was 23 or 24,
he was depicting scenarios in which those two parables could be seen to argue
with one another on justice question on the value and the importance of labor.
And so while the parable of the talents seemed to be chiding Milton for,
for not working hard enough and not working fast enough,
the parable of the workers in the vineyard seemed to assure him in some way that
he didn't need to work quite so hard that God didn't require his incessant and
laborious efforts.
Um,
it's a,
it's a measure of just how difficult Milton wants it to be for us to adjudicate
between Adam and eve in this,
in this book that he casts their argument in the injustice language,
the language of political economy about work.
It's an argument that involves all of the implications.
I think of those two,
what are from Milton,
those two highly charged parables now,
I think it's almost impossible for us to come to this scene without some
assumption that that eve is wrong.
We assume this and we're,
you know,
it's understandable.
We assume that because eve we'll as we know,
we will,
we'll go on to disobey the prohibition of the fruit that she must,
therefore at this point on some level be wrong.
There's something some way mistaken,
uh,
during this conversation.
But Milton Milton,
Milton takes some amazingly interesting steps,
I think to counter what he knows will be our immediate assumptions.
And he attempts to count or counter our assumptions by allowing eve to voice
that position in the dialogue that most look most closely resembles the parable
of the talents.
So,
uh,
look at page three 83 in the Hughes.
This is booked nine line 201
yeah.
So a book line in book nine,
line 201.
First of all,
it's the narrator.
It's the narrator here who's opening the subject of work.
This is line two oh one.
He's,
he's discussing the topic of conversation between Adam and Eve at the beginning
of their day.
They commune,
they converse,
they calm you,
and how that day they may best,
they best may apply.
They're growing work for much.
Their workout grew the hands dispatch of,
to gardening so wide.
So we learned from the s the official perspective of the narrator here that eve,
we'll have children.
This is incredibly consequential information,
uh,
that,
that she was to have children even before the fall.
And we learned,
we learned that even before they have children.
This garden demands an extraordinary amount of work from Adam and eve that the,
that the garden seems in some way to be actually spinning out of control.
This is,
this is a,
this is a nightmare landscape from,
from,
uh,
from the perspective of a,
of a house owner.
Um,
I,
I think this passage is important because it's the narrator here who validates
eaves initial position in this first speech.
So eve suggests that when Adam and eve worked together,
they're affectionate looks.
They're absolutely adorable.
Smiles distract each other from their labor.
Uh,
this is line 23 of book nine.
So all of those intervening looks and smiles.
She argues intermit intermit our day's work brought to little,
there'll be gone early and the hour of supper comes on,
earned
our intermit,
our day's work,
brought to little,
there'll be gun early and the hour of supper comes unearned.
Eve as clearly embraced the Protestant work ethic.
And,
and she displays an intuitive grasp of the importance of the parable of the
talents.
God only rewards those who exert themselves or who invest their talent in an
activity.
And it's,
it's,
it's impossible not to ascribe to eve at least some of the authority that's
attached to the parable of the talents here.
Now,
Adam counters eve with some,
some version of the parable of the workers in the vineyard,
uh,
claiming that there's more to work than simple productivity.
This is line two 42.
Adam's talking for not to Erc some toil,
but to delight.
He made us and delight to reason joined for Adam.
One is still serving God.
When one takes pleasure in one's in one's work.
The important lies more in the willingness to serve and not in the actual amount
of of work that's been accomplished or in the amount of stuff that's been
produced.
And Milton himself was obviously always wanting to take Adam's side in this
debate,
but he seems to have been continually fearful,
at least this is my assumption that eve was right,
that God requires our continual labor.
You can also hear Milton making a distinction between eve zeal for labor and his
own efforts in,
in writing this very writing,
this very poem,
Milton's poem we remember had been long in choosing but beginning,
late,
long and choosing,
but beginning late like the workers in the vineyard,
Milton doesn't get around to writing the poem until late in his literary career.
And Eve's Labor is,
is uh,
is begun early.
And there's even the sense here that beginning early isn't good enough for,
for eve,
she seems to be pushing to get up even earlier and to work even harder.
Eaves is the modern voice of,
of workplace efficiency.
She supplies the voice of conscience.
That child's not only Adam,
but the voice of conscience.
That seems always to be chiding the poet,
the poet himself.
Now Adam,
surely Adam is right.
We have to hand it to him.
He's right in arguing that they are not in a position to earn their suppers as
if they were merely wage laborers.
That's not how it were.
Milton's Milton's even works.
None of their labor actually goes into the harvesting or the production of food.
They're flat,
they're fed plenty.
But that's because the fruits,
I'm simply land in their hands.
Um,
the work that they perform is all entirely ornamental.
It's ornamental gardening,
pruning,
cutting back,
propping up.
It's,
it's never productive in any kind of economic sense or quads.
Economic Sense.
Their gardening is merely a virtuous activity that is entirely divorced from the
demands of productivity or the demands of,
of nourishment.
So Adam is right and,
but,
but while Adam is right in a certain sense,
he doesn't address directly the problem that the narrator himself has already
acknowledged.
And that's the problem that the garden seems to be growing at a faster rate than
Adam and eve are able to manage.
It's a,
this is amazing.
Look at line.
Look at line 205 this is where eve notes how excessive the growth patterns seem
to be in,
in in paradise.
So Adam Eve to Adam,
Adam,
well maybe w well may we labor still to dress.
This garden's still to tend plant herbs and flower are pleasant task and joined
but till more hands eight us to work under our labors grows luxurious by
restraint.
What we buy day Lop,
overgrown or prune or prop or bind one night or two with wanton growth.
Derides tending to wild.
And I think eve here makes an absolutely central argument and it's not an
argument that a,
that Adam counters and I think it's not an argument that Adam would even be
capable of countering.
And that's the idea that the garden is on some level growing out of control,
that the vegetation is literally here tending to wild and it's tending to wild
because Adam and eve are continually cutting it back.
That's their pleasant task and joined the work under our labors grows luxurious
by restraint.
So eve isn't simply describing natural growth patterns in the garden.
She's examining the effects on nature of the imposition of culture.
And we're reminded here of the,
of the etymological a origin of our notion of culture,
which involves the cultivation of the land.
Uh,
it's an agricultural metaphor.
And,
and in this respect,
eve can be seen to articulate something like a theory of culture.
Enter theory has everything to do with the,
our understanding of the fall,
not as a theological problem,
but our understanding of the fall as a cultural problem.
According to Eve,
the garden is,
is wilding,
it's growing disobedience,
but it's not growing disobedient out of any natural necessity.
But because of Adam and Eve's cultural imposition of restraining,
its that pruning and propping and lopping and binding,
and if left to itself,
for all we know,
who knows,
I think this is a perfectly reasonable scenario.
If left to itself the grow,
the garden might actually grow at a reasonable,
moderate,
orderly pace.
But this new disorderliness in the garden,
this wildness seems to be the result of the unnatural cultural attempt to
restrain that natural order.
So think,
think of what the sink,
think of what this is.
God's God's command to Adam and Eve to restrain the garden is on some level a
miniature version of is much more consequential commandment to refrain from
eating the fruit from the tree of knowledge.
And I think that even this speech presents us with a reading of the significance
of the more important commandment.
But of course this is a reading that is incredibly subversive and that's why we
rely so much on eve when we read this poem.
She's the,
she is so magnificently the voice of the subversive,
the imposition of law,
if I'm reading eve correctly here,
the imposition of law doesn't control disorder.
It produces disorder that there's a sense in which the arbitrary interdiction of
the fruit sets in motion and inexorable process whereby the interdiction has to
be broken and they're there.
This is obviously a sense of the fall that Milton cannot permit,
uh,
within the official parameters of the,
of the poems dominant doctor.
And even though it,
this theory,
even subversive theory does come actually rather close to a number of Paul's
statements in the epistle to the Romans.
Um,
but officially in the poem that the fall is an act of free will.
It's a Freeling undertaken choice.
But according to Eve's embedded prophecy of the fall,
there's,
which is what I take this to be,
there's no such thing really as free will.
The father's prohibition seems to necessitate in some way their disobedience in
the same way that pruning a tree and we know this to be a fact pruning a tree
forces or necessitates new growth.
It's almost as if eve we're suggesting that there was something like a,
an organic natural necessity to the fall.
Now I think that's,
that's one way in which Milton looks back at his former interest in work at the,
at his former interest in those,
the interaction of those two parables and he's bending their implications in
their meanings,
um,
in an entirely new way here.
But there's another way in which the separation dialogue looks back at and
essentially uses the essential material from Milton's earlier career.
And this is Eve's staggeringly brilliant deployment of the central argument from
area epigenetics,
the 1644 anti licensing tract.
Look at line 320 of book nine.
This is page three 86 in the Hughes.
Now,
Adam has claimed that they can best pass the trial of Satan's temptation if
they're together,
perfectly reasonable.
Um,
if Adam is there to guide eve and to protector,
um,
the fall is the less likely to happen.
But to eve,
and this is Edes argument,
this sounds as if Adam were attempting to sensor to sensor her environment as if
he were trying to protect her from a potentially dangerous,
potentially dangerous speech of the temperature.
And of course that is what he's trying to do.
And so she,
she responds to what she hears,
uh,
to be Adam's paternal solicitude.
And this is eve at line three 22
if this VR condition
thus to dwell in narrow circuits,
straightened by a foe,
subtle or violent,
we not endued single with like defense were ever met.
How are we happy?
Still in fear of harm?
And this is a,
this is a,
this is a devastating question.
Um,
eve issues,
a powerful critique of Adams,
what she takes to be Adam's act of censorship.
And when she suggests that she is living in an in an increasingly narrow
circuits straightened or constrained by,
by a foe,
it's almost as if she's alluding to Milton's declaration,
his declaration and [inaudible].
I cannot praise a fugitive and cloistered virtue.
You remember these lines.
I cannot praise a fugitive and cloistered virtue unexercised and,
and breathed that never Sally's out and sees her adversary.
What is virtue?
Milton had asked an area politica what is it if it's never tested,
what is virtuous resistance if there's nothing there actually to resist.
If the information one is being given as continually being licensed and censored
and controlled,
Eve refuses to accept the idea that Eden might be structured like an
authoritarian state like,
like,
like the Stuart monarchy and at line three 37,
she lets loose a,
this is a searing criticism of a paradise in which an individual cannot be
relied upon to choose freely her own actions.
Um,
three 37 let us not then suspect our happy state left so imperfect by the maker
wise as not secure to single or a combined now.
And the syntax is a little difficult there.
She's saying,
let's not imagine that we're unsafe here.
Um,
let's not doubt that the main maker created us secure by which he means safe,
whether we're on our own safe,
whether we were on our own or whether we're together and then she continues.
Frail is our happiness.
If this be so and Eden,
we're know Eden thus exposed
eve here is ex.
She's exposing the an ideological contradiction at the heart of,
of Milton's Eden and at the center of her argument is a powerful alternative to
the official poet.
The the official line of Milton's poem eve is pronouncing.
This is we.
This is the structure of a theological argument.
This is a theodicy.
She's justifying the ways of God to men as she sees them,
and this is the logic I take it of what she's just said.
If I am not free to resist temptation alone,
then this is not a justifiable world.
If not,
if I am not free to,
to resist temptation alone,
God is not a justifiable God.
Eden,
we're know Eden thus exposed and therefore she concludes,
I must be free to resist temptation alone.
That's her logical conclusion.
Now eves claim for the true state of Eden is a lot like Milton's claim some 20
years earlier in area politica for the true state of,
of England,
there is at base,
uh,
and equality,
a state of equality among human human individuals and the individual himself
singly and not combined the individual should be empowered to resist temptation
alone that the poem has gone to great lengths to make the official case for
gods.
How can it not?
It's a,
this is a version of genesis at the official case for God's imposition of an
arbitrary set of hierarchical distinctions,
excuse me.
And,
and,
and for his,
uh,
and,
and for Milton's ability to impose or for God's ability to impose arbitrary law,
Milton is supporting that,
uh,
throughout the poem.
But paradise lost is also willing to identify just those arbitrary hierarchies
as something like the source for Eden's imperfection.
And he does that even though even as he celebrates God's ability to impose these
arbitrary distinctions,
it's,
it's this exposure of Eden structural flaws.
I think the belts that best helps us understand the internal dynamics of the
temptation scene.
When Satan tempts eve,
he invariably tempt Sir with some version of all of those desires and all of
those aspirations that Eden's hierarchical culture has struggled and struggled
mightily to,
to suppress.
So our,
um,
look at the top of page 391.
This is line five 38 of book nine.
Our first encounter with eve involved,
you'll remember this suppression of her admiration of that beautiful image that
she saw in the pool or the suppression of what came later to be interpreted as
something like her narcissism eve was created with what seemed to be a natural,
uh,
beautiful and instinctive admiration for the image that she found in the pool.
That,
that that admiration was of course entirely innocent because eve had no way of
knowing that that was her own image.
But with the onset of that mysterious warning voice,
Eve was turned away from that image of herself and her behavior became branded
as narcissism thereafter.
It wasn't of course true narcissism,
but,
but the imposition of that new restraint upon her seems to have produced in eve,
created in her something like a true narcissism and it's this culturally
produced.
This is a character flaw that we can identify as a culturally produced one and
it's one that Satan is able to exploit with utter ingenuity at the temptation
scene.
So this is Satan at line five 38 to eve fairest resemblance of dye maker faire,
the all things living gaze on all things line by gift and by celestial beauty,
adore with ravish meant be held their best beheld where universally admired.
So eaves affection for a responsive image for a sympathetic gays.
That's all she was getting out of the pool was denied her at the pool.
And this restraint seems to have produced in her something like a self love,
self love that has grown luxurious by restraint and Satan knows that.
And the tendency to narcissism was only one component of,
of her character that's exposed,
that was exposed in the scene at the pool side.
The pleasure that eve was deriving from the answering smiles,
those beautiful sympathetic looks in the pool.
Um,
that,
that pleasure is akin in many ways to the pleasure that a lot of infants derive
from the first moments of there from the first moments of their existence.
The infant's pleasure.
And I'm thinking of the incidents pleasure in its initial interaction with the
mother.
This,
this,
uh,
this shouldn't be surprising.
One of the things that Milton tries to accomplish,
um,
in the narrative of,
of Eve's development is something like a larger theory of human development in
general.
But of course,
unlike all the rest of us,
eve doesn't have a mother and it's the,
it's the role of the mother both in culture and in nature that has been
systematically excluded necessarily,
but nonetheless,
systematically excluded from paradise lost and whatever experience of a kind of
maternal affection that Eve may have felt in the answering looks in the
sympathetic smiles,
uh,
is summarily cutoff with the warning voice.
So just as he did with her narcissism,
Satan tempts eve with precisely that natural phenomenon,
that natural instinct that's been denied her.
Look at,
look at Satan mine five 78.
He describes his first glance at the goodly tree,
far distant to behold.
And we of course know what that goodly tree is.
So the serpent says,
I nearer drew to gaze when from the bowels,
a savory odor blown,
grateful to appetite,
more pleased.
My sense then smelled sweetest fennel or the teats of you,
or goat dropping with milk at even unsuccess of lamb or kid that tend their
play.
Surely we all agree that this is a surprising in it and a strange simile here in
comparing this,
the smell of the forbidden fruit,
uh,
to mother's milk.
Satan is offering even embedded image of the mother.
And by placing the scene in the,
in the evening or what he calls even,
Satan is able to insert Eve's actual name into the expression of the natural
desire to suckle,
uh,
at the,
at the mother's breast.
But what,
but what's at stake here isn't simply,
um,
isn't simply Eve's longing for the mother that she never had.
This situation is a lot more radical than that because at the scene,
at the pool in so many ways,
eve was actually mothering herself,
um,
on at least on an experiential level.
Um,
eve seem to have been,
this is the way she must have felt it.
Subjectively.
She was the source of her own creation a lot,
much as Satan claim that he had raised himself by his own quickening power.
Eve had represented the possibility for the poem of something like an absolute
self possession and an absolute self containment.
And you remember that Adam had informed Raphael and book eight,
this was the line five 47 of book aid that he had been struck by this incredible
era of self contained sadness that eve had a,
when I approached her he tells or Raefiel when I approached her loveliness.
So absolute,
she seems and in herself complete.
And Raphael of course hasten to warm Adam against the attraction to females self
sufficiency,
that there's a sense in which eve is absolutely independent.
She's mother and daughter United in one self determining being and it is just
this maternal self sufficiency that the law of the garden has denied eve and so
like clockwork,
it returns here in Satan's temptation.
The third element of Satan's temptation involves the taboo that was established
by Raphael.
This is the taboo of,
of speculation.
Raefiel had told Adam,
don't concern yourself,
don't worry so much about speculating about the cosmos because the structure of
the cosmos simply doesn't concern you.
Be Lowly wise,
Raefiel told Adam no to know no more.
How on Earth could Milton the author of Aereo Politica put those words in the
mouth of the Archangel.
Uh,
it's too troubling even to speculate about,
but look,
look,
look down at line 602 of book nine.
This is page three 92 the serpent argues that one of the effects of the fruit
was the awakening.
And of course he's lying.
Was it the awakening in him of the power of reason,
wakening and him his capacity for speculation thins fourth to speculations,
high or deep.
I turned my thoughts and with capacious mind considered all things visible.
And Heaven or earth or middle,
all things fair and good.
No form of speculation has been licensed or censored for the serpent.
According to Satan,
he gets to think whatever he wants.
His is a vision.
This is exactly the vision of the liberal miltonic universe represented.
So majestically and so compellingly and [inaudible] Politica and again,
the temptation to speculate is intimately linked with this cultural law,
this risk against speculation,
the restraint
of speculation.
And finally,
and most importantly,
eve is tempted with just that aspect of her status,
that this poem has most vigorously denied her.
And that's the possibility.
And I think it's,
I take this very seriously,
that there is a possibility that she's actually,
at least on a natural and ontological level,
she is Adams equal.
The possibility of the,
uh,
of the fundamental or natural egalitarianism of eve,
of Eden rather is one of the principal objects of cultural suppression in
Raffles,
long discourse with Adam,
a Rah Rah fields,
denial of their equality really feels,
uh,
the,
the pages of book eight.
And so naturally the desire for equality surface is one of the principle motives
for Eve's transgression by eating the fruit eve.
Perhaps this is unspeakably heartbreaking by eating the fruit eve perhaps can
produce in herself and equality with Adam.
That's the fantasy and the speaking serpent provides the best evidence.
Imagine imaginable of the alleged ability of the fruit to function as a kind of
chemical equalizer attempt.
T uh,
this is like a,
it's like a testosterone laced cocktail that offers the false hope of equality.
Look at line six 87 Satan to eve.
Look on me,
me who have touched and tasted yet both live and life more perfect have attained
than fate meant me by venturing higher than my lot.
Eat this fruit and you will become greater than you have up to this point.
Been allowed to be eat this fruit and you will become greater than your lot in
life permits.
Now,
this has to be one of the most powerful inducements as a,
as a political philosopher,
Milton knows better than anyone the power of the desire for equality.
And it's just this promise of equality that is the most in that that's the most,
that is most important to eve after she has eaten the fruit.
This is after the fall.
This is line eight 16 of book nine.
This is the middle of page three 97 and Eve as musing to herself,
but to Adam in what sort shall I appear,
shall I to him make known as yet might change and give him to partake full
happiness with me or rather not,
but keep the odds of knowledge in my power without copartner.
So to add what wants in female sex,
the more to draw his love and I love this and render me more equal and perhaps a
thing not undesirable,
sometime superior for inferior who is free.
There is an unspeakable pathos charging these lines because it becomes clear
that one of the primary reasons that Yves has fallen in the first place involves
a structural problem inherent in the miltonic paradise.
The,
and that's the official insistence on a social hierarchy.
Uh,
of course the poem has continually arguing that social end for inferiority does
not impinge upon human freedom.
Just because eve is inferior to Adam doesn't mean that she isn't free but Milton
and perfect.
That's the,
that's the official line.
But Milton knows perfectly well that the radical type of freedom for which he
had argued in his early career as a polemicist had been founded upon an
assumption of equality and an area of pathetic and Milton had implied that we
are all free.
We're all free to read whatever we want because we are all equally endowed with
reason.
That's at least implicitly as argument paradise lost had instituted at the heart
of its body politic,
a distinctly hierarchical society.
There,
there may be a natural instinct for equality.
There's a natural instinct for a quality that we feel both without Adam and with
eve,
but the official culture of Eden has labored to suppress that instinct.
And at the moment of the temptation,
the tremendous cost of that suppression is measured.
Now from the,
from the dock trial point of view,
eve is clearly wrong here to question her divinely sanctioned place in the order
of things we have to see her as wrong,
but there is a voice that counters the poems doctrine and it argues that the
imposition of such an arbitrary law of hierarchy can only produce a
corresponding desire to subvert that hierarchy.
And you'll note here that if the further point that the denial of equality
doesn't merely precipitate a desire for equality,
I think it pushes us even further to a desire.
It's really wild.
It per the denial of equality actually pushes us even further to it to a desire
for superiority.
Even entertainment's the the,
the lovely thought of being,
and isn't this a wonderful phrase,
the lovely thought of being sometime superior as,
as if Adam and eve could assume different positions on the hierarchical ladder
at will as if Adam and Eve could either rung,
assume or both.
Just as a Milton's angels can either sex,
assume this is the suppression of equality even pushes eve to that.
Perfectly illogical but completely understandable formulation.
She'd like to be more equal as if you quality could be quantified in some way.
Um,
as if he quality weren't a relational phenomenon,
a structural phenomenon,
but one
that could be assumed entirely by oneself,
that one that could be hoarded and kept within the self in quantity.
No,
according to the official doctrine of the poem,
uh,
the,
the moment of Eve's eating of the fruit is the origin of the human condition.
The original human condition of fallen us man lived until this time in a state
of Paradise Hill perfection and it's out of an APP.
It's out of an absolutely freewill that man chooses to disobey the divine
command.
But the narrative that Milton employees to illustrate this official doctrine
seems continually to be questioning just that assumption.
Milton's poetry seems to counter this,
this belief and even Edenic perfection and counter this belief and even an
Edenic freedom.
But before the fall,
there's a sense in paradise lost that Adam and eve were neck.
And I know this as heretical,
that Adam and eve were never completely free in Eden.
They were always burdened.
They were always burdened by a set of cultural constraints of which the
prohibition of the fruit was simply the most outrageous,
but certainly not the only one.
Look at page 402 this isn't an another important moment after the fall line,
this is the moment in which Adam and eve wake up after their first,
their first act of sexual intercourse after the fall.
This is their first attempt to fall asleep,
which of course doesn't turn out to be that pleasant.
So up they rose as from up they rose is from unrest and each the other viewing
soon found their eyes how opened and their minds how darkened innocence that as
a veil had shadowed them from knowing ill was gone.
Just confidence and native righteousness and honor from about them.
Naked left to guilty.
Shame.
So this is Milton's version of the genesis text.
This is what genesis tells us.
The eyes of both were opened and they knew that they were naked.
They've awakened to a new,
uh,
to a new form of consciousness.
But Milton wants us to know that this new form of knowledge,
this new self consciousness isn't an enlightenment.
It's a darkening their minds.
How darkened Milton exclaims.
But it's so much more complicated than that.
No sooner has Milton depicted the fall as a darkening.
Then he does something incredibly strange.
He describes the fall from innocence as if the fall we're in itself,
something like an enlightenment innocence that as a veil had shadowed them from
knowing ill was gone on.
And there's an incredibly complicated but wonderfully contradictory interplay of
lightening and darkening and the,
and the imagery here begins to deconstruct itself.
On the one hand,
the fall darkens their minds and on the other hand they're enlightened as the
shadow we vale is,
is lifted.
And it's at this moment that the poem seems to expose the fictional status of
its representation of something like a perfect [inaudible] innocence.
Surely we expect it's Milton to say something completely different.
Surely we expected Milton to say that innocence was the natural naked Adam and
eve and that this innocent nakedness is now being covered with a veil,
a veil of guilt or avail of shame.
But Milton's doing of course,
exactly the opposite.
What does he say?
Innocence was itself the veil.
The very idea of their perfect and fallen state was the veil.
The very notion that Adam and eve ever lived in a fair pair,
a free paradise was a veil.
It was a fiction.
It was a false covering,
avail thrown over the Edenic society.
That was always an already a product of fallen cultural constraints.
Now,
I don't need to remind you this because I,
I know this is what you're thinking.
We have of course,
run into the image of the veil.
Before in paradise lost an image of the veil appeared in the description and the
length of Eve's hair.
Remember that was a fact of culture that was being mistaken by the narrator as a
fact of nature.
I'm in book four line 304 the narrator,
and you don't need to move there because you remember these lines.
The narrator tells us that eve as a veil down to the slender waisted or
unadorned,
golden tresses war disheveled,
but in wanton ringlets waived as the vine curls her tendrils,
which implied subjection.
And our first understanding of Eve's subjection to Adam was derived from the
length of Eve's hair,
which she wore as a veil.
A veil,
of course,
is only worn to hide something.
It's a covering of a source of shame that in this case meet may have seem to be
eads nakedness,
but that equation of Eve's hair with avail took place.
Think of it,
it took place before the fall,
before nakedness,
which shameful.
And the poem never seen the,
and the poem seem to raise the possibility that there was,
that there was actually never a moment at which Adam and eve were entirely free
from the kinds of constraints and the kinds of prohibitions that we associate
with fallen culture,
with culture after,
uh,
the,
the breaking of the prohibition.
And it's of course,
no accident that the image of the veil occurs in book four in the,
in the context of our introduction to identic hierarchy to the fact of Eve's
subordinate status.
Because the fall itself seems in so many ways I think to to be one of the
natural consequences of this or cultural consequences of this fact of sexual,
uh,
subordination.
Milton's strange image of the veil of innocence in book nine.
What is this?
This is a paradox,
a rhetorical paradox and this paradox announces what is essentially that paradox
circle construction of Eden,
of Milton's Eden on the official,
on the dock trynna level of the poem.
The falling of this veil of innocence exposes Adams and Eve's nakedness.
It's a sign of their new fallen consciousness of their shame.
That's how we're supposed to be reading,
presumably this image.
But this paradoxical image also works on that other level on the much more
subversive level of the poem.
And it exposes a structural flaw at the heart of Milton's paradise.
Milton,
let's the duck trinal veil fall from the poem and he exposes his own alliance
and I really believe this,
he's exposing here is own alliance with eaves critique of Eden's arbitrary
hierarchy.
And it's as if Milton had torn the veil of Dogma from his poem,
and he's begun to realize what Yves has known all along Eden.
We're know Eden thus exposed.
Okay.
That's it.